comme chaque année le rugby club de
saint quentin en yvelines s'associer une
action de solidarité
cette fois ci c'est à l'association
laurette fugain qui rompt les dons et
recettes de la buvette lors d'un match
de championnat contre athis-mons commune
de l'essonne soit dormir le club
dispense le club ami nautisme ans et
aujourd'hui notre adversaire mais
mettrait de rugby c'est l'amitié d'abord
donc avaient organisé l'an passé donc
une action caritative autour des restos
du coeur nous amuser avions participé et
nous avions appris à cette occasion que
le club dispose que l'un des joueurs de
claude ismaël perdu son temps piqûre
d'une d'une leucémie
l'association a en effet pour objectif
de sensibiliser au don de plaquettes et
de moelle dans la lutte contre la
leucémie
elle a été créée en 2002 par stéphanie
fugain la maire de lorette décédé à 22
ans d'une leucémie
c'est aussi par le biais du créateur du
site internet du club sportif et de
l'association que le lien c'est fait ce
dernier a réalisé gratuitement le
nouveau site de l'association et
soutient cette action le combat porte
principalement sur le fait d'informer le
public sur le don le don de plaquettes
le don de moelle osseuse et le don de
sang mais surtout les deux premiers
pourquoi parce que les malades atteints
de leucémies ont un grand besoin de ces
dons là et que si on leur donne pas tout
simplement il meurt prochain moment fort
pour l'association laurette fugain les
concerts return to rock les 19 et 20
novembre à la cigale à paris dont les
recettes lui seront intégralement
reversés